[Music]
ridiculous ridiculous transitions
okay what's up mkbhd here so let's talk
max
with apple silicon i have some thoughts
so there's been a ton of tech events
especially apple events in the last
couple months lately today was the final
one of 2020 the one more thing event and
this is where we all were expecting to
see the first mac with apple silicon and
i know right off the top that's actually
kind of niche as far as like who might
be interested in that specifically but
for me
and maybe it's just a nerd inside me
this was actually the one i was most
excited for most people would probably
pick the iphone events but this is one i
don't know i was just very curious about
i mean i'm already mostly a mac user i
edit in final cut pro i've seen the
struggles of what apple's had to deal
with working with intel and the
limitations of intel's chips and their
laptops and desktops so i'm trying to
figure out what what are they actually
going to do how good can the apple
silicon mac be versus what we already
have so actually leading up to the event
i thought and this i talked about this
on the waveform podcast
i thought it would be either a massive
jump in efficiency
or a massive jump in performance
now you might say all right efficiency
works because you could have the same
laptop with the same form factor and
size the same power but twice the
battery life like that would be an
amazing benefit of apple silicon or
maybe they do performance maybe they do
same battery life same size same laptop
but it's twice as fast
i was curious which one they would pick
and then we saw it and it turns out they
did both so they unveiled the first
apple made chip for max it's called the
m1 chip i figure the m stands for mac
but then again the apple watch has the
s6 chip but the w chip is in the
headphones w1 and w2 and then the iphone
has the a14 bionics so i don't know
maybe m doesn't stand for mac but it's
the m1 chip here and this chip is super
impressive now of course asterisk all we
have right now is claims we don't have
an actual m1 chip mac sitting in front
of us so all we can go by is what they
said on stage apple's usually pretty
good about delivering what they say on
stage but
just listen to these claims so the m1 is
a five nanometer chip with eight total
cores four high performance cores and
then four high efficiency cores so it's
kind of similar to what we've seen on
ipad and iphone a series chips but it's
not just the cpu it's a bunch of things
all put together on the same what we'll
call system on a chip and they're all
integrated together so there's the eight
core cpu we talked about but there's
also an integrated gpu there's the
neural engine 16 core neural engine and
the ram is also built in so it's this
tightly integrated soc where all the
pieces talk to each other quickly and
efficiently as possible and where the
controllers and processes between them
are built inside so right away if you
think like me you can already see the
upside and the downside the downside
really just being the ram is built in to
the m1 chip now so you don't have any
more user upgradeable ram at all in any
new mac with an m1 chip but now of
course the upside is you don't have a
separate cpu and gpu and ram all asking
for power you have one very tightly
integrated chip which can create those
gains in like i was saying either
efficiency
or power
and then i got to the first graph so
look at this graph
this is a graph of cpu power per watt
so if the macbook air was operating at
10 watts dropping an m1 chip in there it
just got at two times faster cpu is that
what this means this this chart is kind
of weird they didn't really label the
axes and it's kind of arbitrary there's
not really too many useful numbers in
here it feels very marketing
and like what even is the latest pc
laptop chip we're talking about here it
doesn't say so i don't know but it seems
to be suggesting that this new macbook
air with an m1 chip will be twice as
fast as
something and then they kept going with
all the rest of the benefits of the gpu
the 16 core neural engine
all this stuff i guess you could say got
my attention
and then they started unveiling the
actual max so sure enough the first one
up is the new macbook air this super
thin 13-inch laptop with a new m1 chip
in there now just hold up one second if
you recall the new macbook air refresh
just happened like six seven months ago
i reviewed it and the consensus was
great little machine it's no wonder it's
the most popular laptop apple makes as
long as you don't need to do anything
too power intensive it's pretty great so
along comes this new m1 macbook air and
immediately their claims are huge faster
launching apps buttery smooth animations
instant wake up from sleep thanks for
that craig
a 3.5 x times faster cpu five times
faster graphics performance the storage
is up to twice as fast thanks to a
better controller in the m1 they showed
it gaming they showed it editing
multiple streams of 4k prores video wow
wow a macbook air huh
okay sounds like they want the
performance route sounds like they just
went straight for more power but then
they also got to the battery of this
macbook pro which they say will have 15
hours of wireless web browsing
and 18 hours of video playback which is
apparently six more hours than the last
macbook air so they did both so okay
that's a pretty impressive set of claims
for macbook air 13-inch it'll still
start at 9.99 maybe it's not the machine
for me but that seems to address a lot
of those little maybe it's not quite
powerful enough for extra stuff
and then you just get that and you're
good but then they moved on to the
13-inch macbook pro so again it's the
same design but basically just replaces
the guts inside with the m1 and watch it
fly so 2.8 times faster cpu performance
five times faster graphics performance
again tough to say what they're
comparing it to but those are some
massive numbers either way then they
said it's three times faster than the
best-selling
windows laptop in its class but like
what
what even is the best wind what's the
best-selling windows laptop we all know
the best selling ones aren't the best
performing ones
so what do you compare that's kind of
that's kind of a weird slide but then
again they got to battery and they
dropped 17 hours of web browsing or 20
hours of video playback which is
apparently twice what they were quoting
before twice the battery
in the new macbook pro i'm just
imagining like some of the cross-country
flights i've been on where you're kind
of checking on your battery as the movie
plays to make sure you're not draining
too fast
20 hours of video playback what that so
they they crush battery
and they have big performance gains
some pretty big claims so that will
start at 12.99 and they also did refresh
the mac mini as well which makes sense
because there's no uh dedicated gpus in
those integrated gpu as well so that'll
start at 6.99 so there's three new macs
with the m1 chip so my take is
i am very curious how these huge new
performance gain claims will actually
translate to real life
and also how that lineup will sort of
mesh itself out i know again the macbook
air is the most popular laptop they make
for a reason it's also the cheapest but
also now it seems like it's even more
eating into any reason to buy the
13-inch macbook pro if it's so powerful
they have the same chip they seem like
they'll be roughly equal in terms of
performance but anyway it's not all
sunshine and rainbows these machines are
actually already up on apple.com to spec
and buy like right now if you want to
check them out
and there's some things to keep an eye
on one is no user upgradable ram like i
said on any of these machines so not
only does apple have insane control over
the hardware components talking to each
other for perfect optimization but they
also have insane control over how much
you will pay for a ram upgrade and since
you can never upgrade the ram yourself
you gotta buy the ram from apple then
number two there's no new webcams on any
of these laptops really the hardware is
mostly unchanged i believe the air got a
slightly improved display with p3 color
but generally when they were talking
about the m1 chip giving the laptops
better webcam quality they were just
talking about the image signal processor
not an actual 1080p webcam sadly they're
all still listed with a 720p webcam and
then i also noticed only two thunderbolt
usbc ports
on the m1 macbook pro
see there's always been two tiers of the
13-inch macbook pro one baseline version
which has two thunderbolt ports and then
the higher spec version which has two on
each side so four
the new one with the m1 chip for some
reason
has two
which is odd and fun fact you can
actually still buy the intel macbook pro
if you want you can go to apple's
website
go to the new macbook pro and scroll
down the intel ones are still here and
the higher end one still has four ports
so you get the upside of control and you
get the downside of control apple's just
decided you only need two ports for that
macbook pro even though you're a pro and
then really i believe most of the
biggest numbers we're seeing as far as
performance improvements will come from
the best most well optimized apps and
the ones that apple makes kind of
reminds me of the new consoles actually
so there is still broad app
compatibility because old apps all still
work and you can actually also now use
mac apps and ipad and iphone apps all in
mac os big sur but the biggest
performance improvements those two three
four five x improvements will come from
apps that are actually really well
optimized and that's gonna take time for
developers to work in so it's not gonna
be instant it'll be developing over time
but you'll see stuff like you know the
adobe suite is gonna be working on stuff
in the coming months and there's new
version of photoshop uh that'll be early
next year so that's good so i think the
most important quote of this event was
near the end when they said
the 13-inch macbook pro is the ultimate
expression of what the m1 chip can do
which
yeah i believe that that makes a lot of
sense we were looking forward to what
they could do with a much bigger body
and thermal envelope with apple silicon
and their promising huge performance
literally insane sounding battery life
together m1 chip great but you know what
i'm most excited for
i am most excited for the rest of the
lineup
the desktops because see with the
laptops and the mac mini you still are
optimizing for a lower wattage and a
smaller thermal envelope and you still
need those high efficiency cores to kick
in at the right times to actually
achieve that amazing battery life and
energy efficiency but in the desktops
like when they eventually get to imac
and imac pro and mac pro eventually in
the m2 or whatever they call it
that ship
doesn't have to have so many efficiency
cores right that ship doesn't have to
have the ram built in i hope i don't
think so so really what they can just
optimize for is power power power and so
for me as someone who's been very
impressed with the mac pro's performance
throughout this whole year i cannot wait
to see what types of numbers you would
get just optimizing for power
and the whole rest of that lineup could
be sick it's going to take some time
it's going to be a process we're not
going to see it right away but when we
do
that could be sick all i can do is cross
my fingers that apple doesn't take the
control thing
too far like i said they didn't have to
build in the ram but it made sense for
the laptops and i kind of wonder what
they're going to do with the rest of the
lineup in other chips
but that's what we know so far i we i
definitely got to get my hands on these
laptops and figure out how well the
numbers translate to real life but there
you go for all the people who are asking
me hey should i get a new macbook this
year i'm thinking about a new laptop and
i told you to wait i told you there was
new macbooks coming now they're here you
can literally get them like by the time
you see this video
you're welcome but definitely stay tuned
for the reviews and we'll see how good
they actually are
so either way that's my thoughts that's
been it
thanks for watching
catch you guys very soon
in the next one
peace